La entrada al campo de gotcha,
guerra de pintura,
el gotcha es ese juego,
en el que la gente se dispara bolitas de pintura,
cuesta 5 pesos
y las balas de pintura se venden por separado,
además de la entrada.
Por ejemplo, la entrada y cinco balas cuesta 8 pesos.
¿Cuáles de las siguientes opciones
acerca de la relación
entre el precio
y la cantidad de municiones son verdaderas?
Y me dan todas estas opciones.
Bien, entonces vamos a empezar considerando
esta relación,
así que digamos que sea,
sea "p"
igual al precio el precio,
al precio total que voy a pagar,
es decir, la entrada
más lo que tenga que pagar por las balas.
Y también sea "b" igual al número de balas...
número de balas...
que voy a comprar.
Yo sé que el precio,
va a ser una función del número de balas,
por lo tanto,
puedo hacer una pequeña tablita
en la que ponga el número de balas,
contra el precio que voy a pagar.
Que como dije,
es una función del número de balas en sí.
Entonces bien,
si no compro ninguna bala, compro 0 balas.
Entonces,
solo tengo que pagar la entrada al campo de gotcha,
me aburriría muchísimo pero lo puedo hacer
y me costaría 5 pesos,
así que aquí
con 0 bolas pago 5 pesos.
Y si por el contrario lo que hago es entrar
y comprar 5 balas...
compro 5 balas,
entonces el precio sube a 8 pesos.
Bien,
entonces nosotros podríamos pensar ahora en,
¿cuál es el incremento en el precio
por cada bala adicional que yo compre?
Para calcular eso,
voy a preguntarme cuál es el cambio en el precio
con el cambio en la cantidad de balas
entonces, por ejemplo,
aquí estoy comprando 5 balas adicionales.,
aquí no compraba balas
y aquí cumple 5,
y acá estoy pasando de pagar 5 pesos a pagar 8,
por lo tanto tengo un aumento de tres,
de modo que el cambio en el precio,
dividido entre el cambio en la cantidad de balas
es igual a
pues...
mi cambio en la cantidad de balas fue de 5,
y mi cambio
en la cantidad de precio que voy a pagar...
me cambio en el precio perdón,
no en la cantidad de precio,
sino simplemente en el precio
es de 3, por lo tanto,
la tasa de cambio
de esta función sería de tres quintos
y eso es lo mismo que
0.6...
0.60 si gustan porque
quizás lo pensemos en pesos así que 0.6
Podría con estos datos escribir ya
la función explícita para el precio
podría decir que el precio,
dependiendo de la cantidad de balas,
va a ser igual a...
pues primero tengo que pagar
los 5 pesos de entrada al campo de gotcha,
aunque no compre ninguna bala.
Y luego por cada bala que compre
tengo que pagar
0.6 pesos o
60 centavos
es decir, 5 más
0.6
por la cantidad de balas.
Y hagamos una pequeña gráfica
para ver cómo se ve esto...
aquí tengo mi...
eje vertical que va a ser el precio
este eje va a representar el precio,
y por acá voy a poner mi eje horizontal
que va a representar
la cantidad de balas.
Entonces veamos,
aquí vamos a ponerle incremento de
5 vamos a poner por acá el 10,
por acá el 15 quizás,
y aquí vamos a ponerle 0 balas,
después
5 balas
y por acá 10 balas...
quizás... no sé...
y bien
¿cómo se ve la gráfica?
pues cuando no tengo ninguna bala,
cuando tengo 0 balas,
estoy en 5
y cuando tengo 5 balas
tengo que pagar 8 pesos,
por lo tanto,
mi gráfica pasaría más o menos por aquí
y como estoy asumiendo
que no hay cambio en el precio de las balas dependiendo de la cantidad de balas que compre
esto debería ser una línea recta
y se vería algo así.
De hecho esta función que escribí...
esta acá,
es una función lineal
por lo tanto describe una línea recta.
Ok.
Bueno, ya que hicimos todo eso,
vamos a pensar en las opciones que me dan.
La relación entre el precio
y la cantidad de balas es proporcional,
pues eso no es cierto,
porque si la relación fuera proporcional el precio...
el precio debería ser igual a una constante,
"k"
por el número de balas,
pero entonces,
si no tengo ninguna bala,
aquí en 0,
entonces el precio debería ser 0.
Pero el precio cuando no pagó ninguna bala,
es de 5 pesos,
por lo tanto esto no es cierto.
La entrada con 10 balas cuesta 16 pesos,
pues eso lo puedo checar
a partir de la función que escribí aquí,
simplemente tengo que poner pues
cuánto es el precio por 10 balas,
pues sería
5 más 0.6 por 10
simplemente sustituir "b" igual a 10
y esto me da 0.6 por 10 es 6,
más 5 es 11
por lo tanto ,el precio con 10 balas debería ser de 11 pesos no de 16,
por lo tanto esto tampoco es cierto.
Cuando la cantidad de balas aumenta en 11
el precio aumenta en 6.60
Veamos,
si la cantidad de balas aumenta en 11
entonces podría escribir que
el cambio en la cantidad de balas...
¡uy!
eso casi no se ve verdad...
el cambio en la cantidad de balas...
o más bien, el cambio en el precio dividido
entre el cambio la cantidad de balas
debería ser igual a
pues ¿a cuánto?
siempre tiene que ser 0.6
0.6
pero en este caso me están diciendo
que el cambio en la cantidad de balas es de 11...
es de 11.
Así que algo entre 11 me tiene que dar 0.6
Entonces ¿cuánto sería ese algo?
veamos.
tengo que 0.6 es igual a algo entre 11
y entonces de aquí obtengo que 11 por 0.6
debe de ser igual a ese algo
y 11 por 0.6 es igual a 6.6
Por lo tanto
este signo de interrogación vale 6.6,
o 6 pesos con 60 centavos,
por lo tanto, este de aquí sí es cierto.
Si aumento la cantidad de balas en 11
entonces el precio aumenta
en 6 pesos con 60 centavos.
Y ahora me dicen que si el eje "x"
representa la cantidad de balas
la pendiente de la gráfica de la relación
es 5 tercios
pues aquí tengo la gráfica
donde el eje "x" representa la cantidad de balas
y la pendiente...
que recuerden es el alza entre el avance
es veamos
pues aquí si aumente...
si aumente la cantidad de balas,
el cambio en la cantidad de balas
es igual a 5,
entonces le corresponde un cambio en el precio
¿de cuánto?
pues este aumento en la cantidad de precio,
debe ser igual a 3,
por lo tanto la pendiente de esta recta...
la pendiente de esta recta es
3 entre 5
y no 53
por lo tanto éste tampoco es cierto
y solo esta tercera opción es la correcta.